[Music]  pirates had infected the Seas for  generations  so I vow to eliminate them all  [Music]  and then there was this boy  [Music]  general  [Music]  he took everything from me  rage  the dad I've taken to see I've heard  stories the mighty Spanish captain my  son to be killed thousands of men no no  no men go pirates pirates I once knew is  funnier than something in Spanish  he's coming future  personal [ __ ] the crew  your pants Jackie I'm so sorry we're  still talking the stores height  find Spyro for me  this moment on we ought to be our lives  chittering where your left hand as I  said we move man  I'm gonna keep the trouble horrible way  to leave  you paying for what you did  then on that show are looking for  jackets I'm going to swim for it Kareena  stop that no no no no no that's not it  this has gone far enough  no it has not I saw her ankles you've  just seen a lot more if you kept your  cakehole shot  you